there is the possibility
that as faithful as we've started out
and as faithful as we intend to be
that um
changes will come into effect uh what i
call the butterfly effect
which i'm sure you know being the
audience you are you all
understand because you've read ray
bradbury's the sound of thunder you know
you step on a butterfly and the place
the scene and it seems very
minor but uh suddenly you return to the
future and
all of human history has changed because
uh of that butterfly a small change
can produce large changes later on and
that's
uh that's a question on the show i mean
we've already seen in the first season
as faithful as it was
at least two significant departures uh
one character
who has uh um his tongue
torn out with hot pincers uh who
later in my books uh
that doesn't happen to him and and he's
around and
and gets involved uh pretty seriously in
some stuff in book three
um he's not gonna be around to do that
so dave and dan are gonna have to remove
that stuff or
create a new character or somehow
address that problem uh
similarly the the great scene in book
one uh or in the
in the first season where carl drogo
confronts the man mago
and uh the the dothraki blood writer
and rips out his tongue uh
terrific scene uh completely made up by
largely by jason momoa
and uh by dan and david uh it doesn't
happen in my books
margot is still alive in the books and
uh still has yet to be
dealt with so these kind of butterfly
effect things may produce
changes down the road but i mean what am
i going to do go back and retroactively
rewrite uh book one maybe i should
that throat scene was great but um
no i i can't let myself be affected uh i
am aware of what they're doing in the
show
i advise dan and david whenever they're
about to hit the butterfly effect and
and sometimes they change according to
that and sometimes they plunge ahead so
the two beasts are the two beasts and
each one is separate from the other